ce que personne ne sait c'est que
pendant toutes ces années de succès vous
vivez le martyre et l'enfer tout
commence le 24 août 1988 vous faites du
delta planan et soudain c'est
l'accident Sylvin bienvenue sur le
plateau de tout le monde a parlé merci
vous êtes né le 7 mai 1955 à Toulouse
oui et vous grandissez dans la banlieue
toulousaine dans le petit village de
forg alors enfance dans un milieu plutôt
bourgeois un père directeur de grande
société Motorola exact qui dirigeait
Motorola à Toulouse qui était une grosse
entreprise à l'époque ouais et venant
d'une famille très nombreuse avec
beaucoup de cousins de donc les tantes
une famille amusante voilà mère femme au
foyer oui elle a élevé ses enfants c'est
son métier alors à la maison pas de
télévision vous lisez énormément bug
d'Anny mais aussi mermose saex enfin on
voit d'où ça vient bah c'est la ville de
la postale Toulouse donc moi j'ai rêvé
de voler quand j'étais enfant et j'ai
effectivement lu
le petit prince vol de nuit les
aventures de Guillaum dans leses les
grands auteurs les grand auteurs de la
postale quoi les grands pilotes quoi
alors vous rêvez de la vie de votre
oncle en fait Albert pigas vous dites il
m'a transmis le virus il a créé la
collection du masque il a eu l'idée de
faire une collection de roman policier
il avait rencontré Agata Christi et il a
créé le masque alors qu'aucune
collection policière n'existait à son
époque et il a fait fortune avec ça
voilà alors votre devise découverte à
l'âge de 13 ans vous suivra toute votre
vie c'est rêve ta vie dit ta vie
deviendra un rêve c'est vrai j'ai lu ça
et ça m'a beaucoup frappé j'ai j'avais
lu une autre phrase à l'époque qui
disait que voler c'était voir le monde
avec les yeux de Dieu ça m'avait
beaucoup plu et j'avais trouvé ça
superbe donc ça ça a effectivement mené
ma vie jusqu'à présent ouais alors
question scolarité après le bac vous
faites une licence en droit ensuite
science pot à l'EP à Toulouse vous
réussissez le concours d'entrée à Lena
oui j'ai été admissible bravo et j'ai
pas continué serait pas capable d'aller
plus loin d'ailleurs c'est bien d'avoir
réussi le concours d'entrée déjà j'ai
fui en Amérique centrale voilà en fait
vous allez faire votre service civil au
Nicaragua là-bas vous êtes chargé
d'escorter le célèbre vulcanologue
Haroun tarzieief qui était venu suite à
une terrible éruption volcanique alors
vous occupez de lui là-bas et cette
mission achève de vous convaincre que
vous devez être journaliste il y a eu
deux raisons qui m'ont donné envie de
devenir journaliste laavenue de tasief
et cette éruption volcanique est
tremblement de terre d'ailleurs qui
allit avec et puis une guerre civile à
laquelle j'ai assisté à l'époque de
somossa dictateur de l'époque et qui m'a
donné envie en voyant débarquer les
journalistes du monde entier qui m'a
donné envie de faire comme eux tout
simplement voà alors en 1979 vous entrez
à la rédaction de France
interre ensuite la télé vous repère vous
présentez coquin Maillard c'est vrai sur
Antenne 2 c'est quoi coquin Maillard
c'était un jeu de sexy folie Pascal
Brugnot à l'époque qui consistait à voir
si un garçon pouvait deviner qui était
sa petite amie au Milie trois autres en
sous-vêtement en essayant de deviner
avec un bandeau sur les yeux la la dériv
enfin le dérivé exact de cquin le conama
était petit quoi voilà c'est drôle
ensuite guilux vous propose de reprendre
la une est à vous qui avait été animé
par Bernard Goulet bonne expérience oui
c'était une expérience de direct sur TF1
qui venait d'être privatisé à l'époque
et qui m'a appris beaucoup et puis
c'était guilux donc il y
avait le côté admiration qui avait chez
un vétéran quoi de sa part ouais en 1990
vous TTF1 pour France 3 qui vous propose
faut pas rêver célèbre émission ça va
durer 9 ans et ça vous vaudra de set
d'or gros succès faut pas arriver oui ça
a très bien marché on était très bien
placé tout de suite après êre à la salle
vendredi soirou et on avait fidélisé un
public qui était qui adorit cette
émission il y avait une côte d'amour
quelques années plus tard vous héritez
de la présentation du remake de la
chasse au trésor qui s'appelle la carte
au trésor là c'est un jeu sur le
patrimoine culturel et historique gros
succès également c'était une idée de
jacques-anttoine qui s'appelait la tête
et les jambes qui avait trouvé un un
dérivé avec Philippe de Dieu leeveux et
la chasse au trésor et là c'était de
deux candidats en hélicoptère qui
couraient après une énigme des roses des
vents et le trésor et il y avait eu
aussi une côte d'amour pour cette
émission là inable ou alors là vous
devenez quand même très très célèbre
quelles ont été les réactions de votre
entourage vos parents par exemple ils
ont réagi comment à ce moment-là mon
père avait jamais pris mon métier au
sérieux il s'était toujours dit que
c'était à part ça qu'est-ce que tu F
d'autres la vieille question et il a
compris vers la fin de sa vie que
j'avais réussi quelque chose quoi il
était admiratif sincèrement un jour j'ai
trouvé dans son tiroir des coupures de
presse avec des photos qui dénotaient
qu' me suivait en fait sans rien dire ou
avec les médias comment ça s'est passé
ben bien vous avez gagné de l'argent à
l'époque un peu pas énormément mais un
peu ou j'ai gagné bien ma vie on va dire
et
l'amour est-ce que cette célébrité vous
a rapporté des conquêtes Sylvain non ah
bon j'étais pas coureur du tout ah bon
non je suis pas du tout coureur j'ai
jamais raisonné de cette façon-là ou
d'accord vous faisz pas ce metier Bonard
non pas du tout quel était le meilleur
moment de toute cette époque la fois où
on a tourné la France vu du CEL en
hélicoptère que je diffusais à l'époque
dans stio Gabriel pour Michel Drucker
ouais et qui est un moment d'euphorie à
TR dans un hélicoptère où on on faisait
ce qu'on voulait quoi on était libre
ouais mais j'ai eu des moments dans la
carte au trésor aussi formidable des
moments d'euphorie incroyable quoi le
regard de Dieu ouais exactement alors
quel était le pire moment non il y a pas
eu de moment difficile honnêtement je
vois pas j'ai pas de mauvais souvenir de
cette époque là c'était survolté ouais
on était sans arrêt obligé de donner
ouais mais il y avait de belles
récompenses à la clé quoi ouais alors ce
que personne ne sait c'est que pendant
toutes ces années de succès vous vivez
le martyre et l'enfer tout commence le
24 août 1988 dans les Hautes Pyrénées
vous faites du deltlan et soudain c'est
l'accident vous vous en sortez par
miracle mais avec un pied presque
arraché vous refusez
l'amputation c'est vrai et là vous
récoltez 1 an et demi d'hôpital 15
greffes et vous prenez l'habitude contre
la douleur de prendre de la morphine on
m'en a donné à l'hôpital c'était obligé
pour tenir le couou ouais et ça étit
très dur d'arrêter ouais mais c'était
prescrit médicalement quoi ouais mais la
douleur était épouvantable on a du mal à
se figurer ce que la douleur physique
c'est quelque chose de très dur la
morphine on vous en a donné à l'hôpital
mais vous aviez aussi des ce que vous
appelez des dealers en blouse blanche
c'est-à-dire des médecins qui vous
prescrivaient de la morphine assez
facilement finalement il y a un type une
fois qui m'a proposé de la morphine de
synthèse mon Fanta ouais c'est ça j'en
ai pris quelques semaines vous disiez le
soir je n'arrive plus à m'endormir sans
médicament au réveil je suis obligé d'en
prendre d'autres je ne sais plus faire
100 bah c'est le problème de la morphine
c'est qu'on s'habitue et qu'on a on en a
besoin quoi
ouais alors vous êtes shooté à la
morphine c'est pourquoi pour augmenter
la la l'efficacité du du produit pas du
tout c'est la douleur c'est la douleur
qui qui est tellement insoutenable que
on en prend quoi certaines fois vous
êtes retrouvé en train de vous shooter
dans les dans les toilettes de bistro
avant d'avoir des rendez-vous
professionnels ça m'est arrivé oui et
c'est là qu'un jour de janvier 2006
France 3 annonce votre départ un
accident de moto où il s'est cassé de
genoux il y a 3 ans syvin Ogier n'a
jamais vraiment retrouvé ses capacités
il a décidé de se reposer il sera
désormais remplacé par Marc Bessou vous
avez pris ça sur la tête comme ça oui
comme ça
oui ça a été
dur j'ai jamais très bien compris
d'ailleurs encore aujourd'hui je me
demande ouais qu'est-ce qu'il avait de
plus que vous Marc Bessou il me
ressemblait ouais c'est
vrai et pourquoi pas pas vous je ne sais
pas je n'en sais rien vous ne travaillez
pas moins bien à l'époque non mais ont
changé la formule il voulait comme
souvent la télévision change une tête en
espérant que ça va changer les choses
quoi ouais je suis parti pourquoi vous
avez pas vous êtes pas
battu je sais pas aujourd'hui vous êtes
nostalgique de cette époque de de France
I de oui un petit peu c' une belle
époque ouais c une époque bénie ouais
très amusante ouais très engagé mais
très amusante ouis vous avez de la
rancune contre quelqu'un
non même les gens qui vous ont virai de
France I j'ai pardonné depuis longtemps
h j'ai appris à
pardonner si c'était à refaire votre vie
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil je serais peut-être moins
insouciant peut-être plus plus au fait
de la réalité des choses et des gens h
vous avez le sentiment d'avoir vécu tout
ça un peu comme un rêve sans vraiment
vous préoccuper de ouais c'est ça de
l'atterrissage j'ai été un peu Sigal
ouais le jour vous allez mourir
qu'est-ce vous voulez qu'on écrive sur
votre tombe Sylvain il nous a beaucoup
fait rêver ouais très
bien très heureux de rallumer la lumière
sur vous Sylvin merci beaucoup Merci à
VOUS Thierry et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de inardy tube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce
bleu